[Music]
my name is dawn I work in the Android
dev rel team and I'm here today to talk
to you about low latency audio on
Android so why is auto latency important
well there are a whole raft of use cases
where the audio latency is directly
proportional to the user experience so
this can be in games where you tap on
the screen and you hear a sound
particularly in rhythm games like Guitar
Hero style games where you're tapping in
response to some rhythmic event and you
need to have audible feedback as quickly
as possible like the longer the delay
between tapping on the screen and
hearing a sound the worse the user
experience also in DJing apps you're
you're tapping on the screen and
manipulating audio and you expect that
audio manipulation to happen in real
time karaoke
where you've got an input which is your
voice and generally you're listening to
a backing track and also your own voice
so if the delay between you singing and
hearing your own voice is too long then
it sounds awful
also in VR we have objects which make
sound in a virtual world and if that
sound doesn't follow you around as your
your head moves in this environment then
it kind of distorts the the reality and
lastly of course there's a whole load of
apps for live performance synthesizers
drum machines looping apps you know
anything which you you press a key and
make a sound you need low latency audio
so with this in mind we built a library
to help developers build these kind of
apps is called oboe and it's available
on github now we just launched version 1
so its production ready able to be
included in your apps today and the way
it works is under the hood it uses the a
audio
API on API 27 and above which is the new
high performance low latency audio
introduced in Oreo and on all the
devices it uses opensl es so basically
the idea is provide a simple easy to use
API which works across the widest range
of devices so rather than we talk about
this API I thought it'd be fun to try
and build a musical instrument in 17
minutes and 23 seconds so before I start
that I'm just going to explain the
architecture so it kind of makes sense
when I'm in the code so we have an app
and I'm gonna build the audio engine
part of this app this audio engine is
going to be responsible for creating an
audio stream that's provided by the oboe
library and we're going to be passing
audio frames of data into this audio
stream ultimately this stream is
responsible for putting data out of the
audio device in this case it will be the
three and a half mil jack on this pixel
excel phone now every time the audio
device needs more information it's going
to give us a call back so we get this
call back loop of hey I need more more
audio data and our audio engine is going
to be passing frames of audio data into
the audio stream for some form of
control we're going to monitor tap
events on the screen so when you tap
down the sound will come on when you
lift up sound will go off okay this
works about 50% at the time of rehearsal
so you know the see what happens okay
first problem I need to log in okay can
you see my screen fantastic
okay so I'm just gonna run the app so
I've kind of got a very simple shell of
an app it doesn't really do anything at
the moment but it just has a few little
shortcuts that make it possible for me
to do this in a very short short amount
of time so I will just run the app on
this pixel excel and hopefully you'll be
able to see that it does nothing so here
we go
here's the app and when I tap on the
screen nothing happens no sound comes
out you know it's it's non-functional I
just want you to know that there's no
smoke and mirrors it is genuinely live
Thank You Glenn okay so we're in our
main activity here and we're going to
talk to the oboe library via Jay and I
so I have a couple of native methods
here which I'm going to use and I'll
implement those methods in a second but
so we're gonna create an audio engine
and we'll start by calling start engine
so let's just jump into our j'ni code so
this is in native Lib cpp here so i'm
going to define an audio engine up here
just call it engine and then i'm gonna
call a method on my engine called start
now i've already created the header and
implementation files just the blank
files for this audio engine class so
i'll go ahead now and write the class so
audio engine and i'm going to have one
method called start ok now i can use
option enter to generate the definition
for this i'm in my implementation and
i'm in the start method before i can
start using the OBO library i need to do
two things number one i need to include
the oboe header
and the other thing I need to do is wear
this kind of just makes it easier for me
which is to use the oboe namespace and
this just avoids me having to prefix all
of the over objects with the word oboe
so in our start method we want to create
an audio stream to do that we use an
audio stream builder that B and the
Builder allows us to set properties on
the stream so that's things like the
format of the stream now when I set the
format there are two choices
I can I can choose from either 16-bit
integers or floats I will use floats I
can also set the number of channels so
that would be two for stereo or one for
mono and I can also set properties which
inform the stream of my latency
requirements so the most important one
here is set performance mode and there
are a number of options but the one I
want is obviously the low latency one
the second thing I can do is set the
sharing mode on the stream so let's just
set that so I'm going to set this to an
exclusive sharing mode and what that
means is that I'm requesting that the
audio device give me an exclusive stream
that means that my apps audio won't be
mixed with any other audio on the system
so if the device supports it I can avoid
having my audio mixed with with anything
else before it goes through through the
speaker or headphones and by doing this
I can cut a few milliseconds of latency
off the output so that's all I need to
do to open the stream so I can go ahead
now and call open stream this takes a
reference to an audio stream pointer
again I can use option enter to create a
new field called stream so in back in
our head oh it's done this automatically
for me okay once the stream is open
there's one final step I need to take
which is to set the buffer size on the
stream so I can do this by doing set
buffer size in frames
now to get the smallest possible buffer
size we have to interrogate the audio
device for the minimum amount of data
that it will read in one operation so a
discreet chunk of audio data and we call
this a burst so we want to obtain the
burst size from the audio device we can
do this using stream get frames per
burst and that's the minimum possible
buffer size that we can we can set our
our stream to have but we actually don't
recommend that you use this this
absolute minimum we recommend that you
use double this because it provides a
good protection against under runs it's
a good trade-off with latency and andand
ok so that's all I need to do to create
a low latency stream so now I can go
ahead and start the stream which will do
nothing because we haven't found any way
of putting data into the stream so to
get data into the stream we use a
callback so I'm back in the Builder and
I'll set or use the set callback method
this is this wants to take an audio
stream callback object and to make this
simple I'll just use my this object
which means that my audio engine needs
to implement this interface so we'll
have it do this now I can use control o
to show me the methods that I can
override in this interface the one I
want is on audio ready this is the
method that will be called every time
the audio device needs more data so
inside here just take a quick look at
what this method signature is so on
audio ready is is called
it tells me the stream that wants more
data and it also gives me a container
array so this container array which is
of type void star because it can be
either 16-bit integers or floating-point
samples is something that I'm
to write my audio data into so I write
it into it and then that's passed out to
the audio device lastly we have num
frames which tells me the number of
audio frames which need to be centered
populated in this container array so I
need an audio source and I'm gonna cheat
a little bit here I have created an
oscillator in advance and let's just
take a quick look at it and it's just
going to generate a square wave here so
that's a periodic signal varying between
two points to create a square wave
so let's now create an oscillator I'll
just do so later after it's a temp
templated object so i need to tell it
what type and I'll just include the
oscillator header so now that I have an
oscillator I can do ask render okay
so Android studio is complaining about
this method signature here that's why
it's got a red underline here I'm just
gonna go ahead and build and that
normally sorts it out yeah there we go
okay
ignore the errors okay so on my
oscillator I have a render audio method
which is going to put the audio frames
from the oscillator into this audio data
array so first thing I need to do is
cast it to this an array of floats data
and passing the number of frames so the
last thing I need to do in an audio
ready is return a result and this can be
either to continue where the callbacks
will continue or it can be stopped and
the callbacks will stop so in my case
I'm going to continue right the final
thing I want to do is set some things up
on my oscillator so I'm going to set the
amplitude which is kind of the volume
I'm also going to set the frequent
see set that at about 80 Hertz nice bass
frequency and I also need to set the
sample rate which tells me it tells the
oscillator how frequently these samples
should be produced and I can get that
from the stream get sample rate there
okay
I know you're all desperate to hear a
sound there is one very very final thing
I need to do here which is I need to
respond to tap events so I'll just go
back into main activity and I'm going to
override the on touch event so that if
the event is down then I'm going to call
this native method tap make that true
else otherwise if the event is up I'm
lifting my finger off the screen then
I'll pass in false okay let's just have
a look at this tap method
this needs implementing so I'll just
pass in this true or false value create
the new method and I just call ask set
wave on and that's going to pass that in
there now moment of truth okay I'm going
to run this and in theory you should
hear a sound
so when I tap on the screen we should
hear an 80 Hertz square wave the
pressure there we go so you can see it's
the lowest possible latency here and
it's actually pretty responsive which is
so so we have a musical instrument
admittedly it's not the best musical
instrument in the world yeah a little
bit to be desired on that on the sound
and control front so what I actually
thought it would be nice is if we could
add a little bit more control so for the
last four minutes and thirty seconds I'm
going to tie the motion sensor to the
pitch of the oscillator so to do this
I'm gonna cheat uncomment some code that
I wrote earlier and what this does is
register a listener which will listen to
the rotation vector sensor so to listen
to these events I need to implement the
sensor event listener interface
implement the methods on sensor change
so what I want to do is set the
frequency based on the event values of
the x-axis and I also need to scale this
value so I want to have it from let's
say from 20 Hertz the limit of human
hearing and let's go up to like so this
this should give me around up to around
100 Hertz so yep that looks good
so again I just need to implement this
frequency
okay so we'll just go ask set of
frequency and there we go okay so we're
good to go on that brief interlude very
brief in fact um has anyone heard of the
are men break okay one person yes
so the are men break comes from a song
in the 60s by the Winston brothers
called
are men brother and it's four bars of
the most incredible drum solo and it's
the most sampled loop in history but no
one's heard of it evidently apart from
one guy so I thought it'd be nice if I
could play my new musical instrument
over this loop so here's the loop I need
to run the app let's give it a go just
make sure it's here okay so with a bit
of luck we go
[Music]
okay right okay so that's that's about
it from me
if we can just go back to the slides and
yes so the library is available on
github there's documentation code labs
all sorts of good stuff on there we'd
love you to start using it start
building amazing audio experiences on
Android yeah and I'll be around
afterwards if you have any questions so
thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]